This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2012 Miranda Dinda had a lot on her plate. She was 18. All her friends were getting ready for college and busy being teenagers. But Miranda was on a different path. She was pregnant. So I was very nervous and I felt really uneasy but excited at the same time. To calm her anxieties Miranda did some research on childbirth. and I felt really uneasy but excited at the same time.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2012年时，米兰达·丁达面临着许多事情。她当时18岁。所有的朋友都在为上大学做准备，忙着体验青少年的生活。但米兰达走上了一条不同的道路。她怀孕了。所以我感到非常紧张，内心十分不安，但同时又很兴奋。为了平复焦虑，米兰达对分娩做了一些研究。内心十分不安，但同时又很兴奋。
To calm her anxieties, Miranda did some research on childbirth. I decided I wanted a home birth. For that, she would need a midwife. She searched for months for someone who could come to her apartment in rural Pennsylvania. Eventually, she found a woman who seemed perfect. We'll call her M, her first initial, to protect her privacy. From the very first moment they met, Miranda knew everything was going to be fine. She said she had been a home birth midwife for over a decade. She was no nonsense, the mother of eight.
为了平复焦虑，米兰达对分娩做了一些研究。我决定要进行顺产。为此，她需要一位助产士。她花了几个月的时间寻找能来她在宾夕法尼亚州乡村的公寓的人。最终，她找到了一位看似完美的女士。为了保护她的隐私，我们用她的名字首字母 M 来称呼她。从他们见面的第一刻起，米兰达就知道一切都会好起来的。她说她做家庭助产士已经有十多年了。她做事雷厉风行，是八个孩子的母亲。
She was very open and honest and friendly, so she definitely seemed like someone who I could trust. About an hour into that first meeting, M brought up a question that struck Miranda as strange. She said, have you ever considered not vaccinating? Miranda hadn't. Vaccines had never crossed her mind. So I asked her, I was very confused. I was like, what do you mean? Why would I consider that? Emme explained that years ago something bad had happened after she vaccinated her first child.
她非常坦诚、真诚且友好，所以她绝对看起来是一个我可以信任的人。在那次初次见面大约一个小时后，M 提出了一个让米兰达觉得奇怪的问题。她说，你有没有考虑过不接种疫苗？米兰达从来没有想过。疫苗从未进入过她的脑海。所以我问她，我当时非常困惑。我说，你是什么意思？我为什么要考虑这个？M 解释说，多年前在她给第一个孩子接种疫苗后发生了一些不好的事情。
She went on to describe a progression of events that lead some parents to a powerful but faulty conclusion. Emptool Miranda, that right after her son got his shots, his development regressed. One minute he was fine, the next he was autistic. She said the light had left his eyes. So Em decided not to vaccinate her other children. And she very much implored me to do the same and to look into it. So I did.
她接着描述了一系列事件的发展，正是这些事件导致一些父母得出了一种强有力但错误的结论。M 告诉米兰达，就在她儿子注射疫苗后，他的发育倒退了。前一分钟他还好好的，下一分钟就成了自闭症患者。她说，他眼中的光芒消失了。因此 M 决定不再给她的其他孩子接种疫苗。她极力恳求我也这样做，并去深入了解一下。于是我照做了。
Miranda started on Google. It led her to Facebook groups. It's very easy to find them. So yeah, even if you just Google support groups for parents who don't vaccinate, you will find a lot. The moms in these groups echoed what M had told her. And they welcomed me with open arms and immediately were just practically bombarding me with information, telling me, your midwife's right, this is why you shouldn't vaccinate.
米兰达开始在谷歌上搜索。这把她带到了脸书群组。找到它们非常容易。所以，是的，即使你只是搜索“不接种疫苗的父母支持群”，你也会找到很多。这些群组里的妈妈们呼应了 M 对她说过的话。她们张开双臂欢迎我，几乎立刻就开始用信息狂轰滥炸我，对我说，你的助产士是对的，这就是为什么你不应该接种疫苗。
This is why I don't vaccinate. This is what happened to my child who I did vaccinate versus my child who I didn't vaccinate, things like that. Everyone was caring and attentive. They didn't just talk about vaccines. They talked about regular mom stuff. Things at Miranda found hard to talk about with anyone else. Dipers and birth plans and hospitals and midwives and breast pumps and stuff like that. Miranda trusted them. and hospitals, and midwives, and breast pumps, and stuff like that. Miranda trusted them. To me, it seemed so clear.
这就是为什么我不接种疫苗。这就是我接种了疫苗的孩子与我没有接种疫苗的孩子所发生的事情，诸如此类。每个人都充满关怀且体贴。他们谈论的不只是疫苗。他们谈论普通妈妈的话题。这些话题米兰达觉得很难跟其他人聊起。比如尿布、分娩计划、医院、助产士、吸奶器之类的事情。米兰达信任她们。医院、助产士、吸奶器之类的事情。米兰达信任她们。对我来说，这一切似乎非常清晰。
It seemed like I had just found this secret information that only some people come across. And I thought, why would I not use this information? Why would I not use this to my benefit, to my child's benefit? So it did not take me very long at all before I was solidly saying, I will not vaccinate my child when she's benefit. So it did not take me very long at all before I was solidly saying, I will not vaccinate my child when she's born.
我好像刚刚发现了这种只有少数人才会偶然遇到的秘密信息。我想，我为什么不利用这些信息呢？我为什么不把这些用对我有益、对我的孩子有益的地方呢？所以没花多久，我就坚决地表态：当我的孩子出生时，我不会给她接种疫苗。用对我有益、对我的孩子有益的地方呢？所以没花多久，我就坚决地表态：当我的孩子出生时，我不会给她接种疫苗。
["Ramona come closer, shut softly, you watery eyes." She named her daughter Ramona after the song by Bob Dylan. ["I'll be the sadness will pass as your senses will rise. Ramona, as a newborn, she was very active. She was very bright. She was very happy. She was a great baby, honestly.
“雷莫娜，靠近些，轻轻闭上你水汪汪的眼睛。”她用鲍勃·迪伦的歌给女儿起名叫雷莫娜。“我相信随着你感官的觉醒，悲伤终会消逝。雷莫娜，作为一名新生儿，她非常活跃。她非常聪明。她非常快乐。说实话，她是一个很棒的婴儿。”
She was a wonderful baby. When the doctor said it was time to vaccinate Ramona, Miranda was ready. She had a script she had been practicing in her head for months. And I said, no thank you, I have decided that I do not want to vaccinate. Please respect my opinions, thank you very much. For the next two years, Miranda continued to say no to vaccines. Occasionally, when she encountered information that conflicted with her decision, a pamphlet at the doctor's office or website, she dismissed it. I just very quickly went that's not true. I don't agree with that and I
她是个极好的婴儿。当医生说该给雷莫娜接种疫苗时，米兰达已经准备好了。她准备了一段在脑海里练习了几个月的台词。我说，不用了谢谢，我已经决定不想接种疫苗。请尊重我的意见，非常感谢。在接下来的两年里，米兰达继续对疫苗说不。偶尔，当她遇到与她的决定相冲突的信息——比如医生办公室的宣传册或网站时，她会将其驳回。我当时很快就会觉得那不是真的。我不同意那个，然后我
moved on. At some point though her conviction started to waver. Those doting moms on Facebook, they had some weird beliefs. People denying that AIDS exists. People saying that there are reason there's gay people as vaccines, on and on and on with really crazy conspiracy theories. And then it hit her. If she didn't believe those ideas, why was she trusting them on vaccines?
就继续往前走了。然而，在某个时刻，她的信念开始动摇。脸书上那些溺爱孩子的妈妈们，有着一些奇怪的信仰。有人否认艾滋病的存在。有人说同性恋存在的原因是疫苗，各种真正疯狂的阴谋论层出不穷。然后她突然意识到了。如果她不相信那些观点，为什么她要在疫苗问题上信任她们呢？
And I stepped back. I stopped going to the Facebook group as much. And I decided I needed to look at this issue from a purely logical perspective. No emotion in it. No, oh my God, what if something happens to my baby? And I completely readdress the issue all over again pretty much from the start.
我退了一步。我不再那么频繁地访问脸书群组了。我决定需要从纯粹的逻辑角度来看待这个问题。不带任何情绪。没有那种“天哪，如果我的宝贝出了什么事怎么办”的想法。我几乎从头开始，完全重新审视了这个问题。
Miranda started seeking out perspectives that the moms had urged her to avoid. Information from the center, so disease control, and medical journals. I started reading all kinds of things, basically opening my mind to more than just vaccines are bad to the other side of the coin. It didn't take her long to change her mind. She got Ramona vaccinated. Looking back, Miranda can't believe how easy it was to embrace beliefs that were false.
米兰达开始寻找妈妈们曾劝她避开的观点。来自疾病控制中心的信息以及医学期刊。我开始阅读各种各样的东西，基本上让自己的思维超越了“疫苗是有害的”这一单一观念，去接纳硬币的另一面。没过多久，她就改变了主意。她带雷莫娜去接种了疫苗。回想起来，米兰达简直不敢相信自己当初竟会如此轻易地接受虚假的信念。
And what I would say to someone who's about to become a new mom, especially if they're a young mom, is don't try to confirm your own fears online. It is so, so easy to Google what if this happens and find something that's probably not true that confirms your fear, that confirms your anxieties. Don't do that. Miranda's story tells us a lot about the psychology of false beliefs, how they spread and how they persist even in the face of conflicting information.
我想对即将成为新手妈妈的人，尤其是年轻妈妈说的是，不要试图在网上证实你自己的恐惧。谷歌搜索“如果发生这种情况会怎样”并找到一些可能并非真实、却能证实你的恐惧和焦虑的信息，实在是太容易了。不要那样做。米兰达的故事深刻地揭示了虚假信念的心理学机制——它们是如何传播的，以及即使在面对冲突信息时它们又是如何顽固存在的。
Today we look at how we rely on people we trust to shape what we believe and why emotion can be more powerful than facts. We start with neuroscientist Tally Sherrett, a professor at University College London. She is the author of the influential mind, what the brain reveals about our power to change others. Tally is a mom and so she understands on a personal level why Miranda was so worried about the safety of her child. A few years ago, when her baby was just a few weeks old, Tally was listening to a Republican presidential debate.
今天，我们探讨我们如何依赖我们信任的人来塑造我们的信念，以及为什么情感有时比事实更有力量。我们首先采访神经科学家塔莉·沙雷特，她是伦敦大学学院的教授。她是《影响力的法则：大脑如何揭示我们改变他人的力量》一书的作者。塔莉是一位母亲，因此她能从个人层面理解为什么米兰达如此担心孩子的安全。几年前，当她的宝宝只有几周大时，塔莉正在收听共和党总统候选人辩论。
Can you take this little beautiful baby and you pump? I mean, it looks just like it's meant for a horse, not for a child. Candidate Donald Trump had been asked a question about the safety of childhood vaccines. And we've had so many instances, people that worked for me just the other day. Two years old, two and a half years old, a child, a beautiful child, went to have the vaccine
你能拿着这个美丽的小宝宝去打针吗？我的意思是，它看起来就像是为马准备的，而不是为孩子准备的。候选人唐纳德·特朗普被问及有关儿童疫苗安全性的问题。我们有那么多实例，就在前几天，在我手下工作的人。两岁，两岁半的孩子，一个美丽的孩子，去打疫苗
and came back and a week later got a tremendous fever, got very, very sick, now is autistic. So when I was listening to Trump at that debate, it really tapped into this fear that I had, and the anxiety that I already had. And when he talked about this huge syringe, a horse-sized syringe that was going to go into the baby in my mind, I could imagine this syringe
回来后一周内发了高烧，病得很重，现在成了自闭症患者。所以当我听到特朗普在辩论中的这番话时，它真正触及了我内心原有的恐惧和焦虑。当他谈到这个巨大的注射器——一个马匹大小的注射器将要扎进宝宝体内时，我的脑海中就能想象出这个注射器
inserted into my small little child and all the bad things that could happen. And this was a very irrational reaction on my end because I know that there's not an actual link between autism and vaccines. But it's not enough to have the data. Ben Carson, Dr. Ben Carson, was on the other end. Well, let me put it this way. There have been numerous studies and they have not demonstrated
插入我那小小的孩子体内，以及所有可能发生的糟糕事情。这对我来说是一种非常不理智的反应，因为我知道自闭症和疫苗之间并没有实际的联系。但仅仅拥有数据是不够的。本·卡森，本·卡森医生，持相反的观点。嗯，让我这样说吧。已经有无数的研究表明，它们并没有证明
that there was any correlation between vaccinations and autism. But that wasn't enough because the data is not enough and even if the data is based on very good science, it has to be communicated in a way that will really tap into people's needs, their desires. If people are afraid, we should address that. I'm curious when you sort of contrasted, you know, the weight of the evidence on the one hand and this very powerful image of the horse syringe and your seven-week-old baby on the other hand, how did you talk yourself into trusting the data over that emotional image?
疫苗接种和自闭症之间存在任何关联。但这还不够，因为单纯的数据是不够的，即使这些数据基于非常好的科学，它的传达方式也必须真正能够契合人们的需求和欲望。如果人们感到害怕，我们就应该解决这个问题。我很好一方面是证据的分量，另一方面是马用注射器和你七周大的宝宝这个极具冲击力的画面，当你把这两者对比时，你是如何说服自己相信数据而不是那个情感画面的呢？
What really helped is that I understood what was happening to me. Because this is what I study, I knew what my reaction was, I knew where it was coming from, I knew how it was going to affect me, and I think that awareness helped me to put it aside and say, okay, I know that I am anxious for the wrong reasons. And this is the action that I should take. It's a little bit when you're on a plane
真正有帮助的是我理解了发生在我身上的事情。因为这是我的研究领域，我知道我的反应是什么，我知道它来自哪里，我知道它将如何影响我，我认为这种意识帮助我把它放在一边，然后说：好的，我知道我是因为错误的原因在焦虑。这就是我应该采取的行动。这有点像你在飞机上
and there's turbulence and you get scared. But telling yourself, I know that turbulence is not actually anything that's dangerous I know the statistics on safety and planes and so on, it helps. It helps people reduce their anxiety. But facts don't always relieve our anxieties. Sometimes they harden our views. Some time ago, Tally wanted to test how people update their beliefs when confronted with new information. So she presented statements to two kinds of people, those who believe that climate change
遇到气流时会感到害怕。但告诉自己，“我知道气流其实并没有什么危险，我知道关于飞机安全的数据等等，”这很有帮助。这有助于人们减轻焦虑。但事实并不总能消除我们的焦虑。有时它们反而会固化我们的观点。不久前，塔莉想要测试当面对新信息时，人们是如何更新他们的信念的。于是她向两类人陈述了一些陈述句：一类是相信气候变化
was real and those who were deniers. She found that for both groups, when the statement confirmed what they already thought, this strengthened their beliefs. But when it challenged their views, they ignored it. Tally says it's because of a powerful phenomenon known as confirmation bias. Confirmation bias is our tendency to take in any kind of data that confirms our prior conventions
是真实存在的人，另一类是气候变化否定者。她发现，对于这两组人来说，当陈述句证实了他们原有的想法时，这会强化他们的信念。但当陈述句挑战他们的观点时，他们就会选择忽视。塔莉说，这是因为一种被称为确认偏误的强大现象。确认偏误是我们倾向于接受任何能够证实我们先前约定俗成的观念的数据
and to disregard data that does not conform to what we already believe. And when we see data that doesn not conform to what we already believe. And when we see data that doesn't conform to what we believe, what we do is we try to distance ourselves from it. We say, well, that data is not credible, right? It's not good evidence for what it's saying. So we're trying to reframe it to discredit it, right? So I give an example in my book where if someone comes in and says,
，而忽视那些与我们既有信念不符的数据。当我们看到与我们既有信念不符的数据时，我们所做的是试图与它保持距离。我们会说，嗯，那个数据不可信，对吧？它不能很好地证明它所说的话。所以我们试图重新构建它来抹黑它，对吧？所以我书里举过这样一个例子：如果有人走进来对我说，
I just saw pink elephants flying in the sky, and I have a very strong belief, obviously, that no pink elephants fly in the sky. I would then think that they're either delusional or they're lying. And there's good reason for me to believe that. So it's actually the correct approach to assess data in light of what you believe. There's four factors that determine whether we're going to change our beliefs.
我刚刚看到粉红色的象在天空中飞翔，而我非常坚信的一点显然是，天空中没有粉红色的大象在飞。我就会认为他们要么是产生幻觉了，要么是在撒谎。我这样认为是有充分理由的。因此，根据你所相信的来评估数据，实际上才是正确的方法。决定我们是否会改变信念的有四个因素。
Our old belief, our confidence in that old belief, the new piece of data, and our confidence in that piece of data. The further away the piece of data is from what you already believe, the less likely it is to change your belief, and on average, as you go about the world, that is not about approach. However, it also means that it's really hard to change false beliefs. So if someone holds a belief very strongly, but it is a false belief, it's very hard to change it with data.
我们原有的信念、我们对那个原有信念的信心、新的数据，以及我们对该数据的信心。数据距离你原本的信念越远，它改变你信念的可能性就越小；平均而言，当你在这个世界上生活时，这不是一种错误的方法。然而，这也意味着要改变虚假的信念是非常困难的。因此，如果某人持有一个非常坚定的信念，但那是一个虚假的信念，用数据来改变它是极其困难的。
So if data and facts don't work, what does? How do you get people to buy the truth? Well, you could try scaring them. The vast majority of Americans today do not feel safe. On Sunday, Americans woke up to a nightmare that's become mind-numbingly familiar. This could be the great trojan horse of all time. Politicians use fear to get us to vote. TV programs use fear to get us to keep watching.
所以，如果数据和事实不起作用，那什么才起作用呢？你如何让人们接受真相？好吧，你可以尝试吓唬他们。今天绝大多数美国人都感到不安全。周日，美国人在一场令人麻木的熟悉噩梦中醒来。这可能是史上最大的特洛伊木马。政客们利用恐惧来让我们投票。电视节目利用恐惧来让我们继续观看。
Public health officials use fear to get us to quit smoking. I asked Tally whether fear might be an effective way to persuade people to change their minds and maybe even their behavior. Fear works in two situations. It works when people are ready, stressed out, and it also works when what you're trying to do is get someone not to do something, an inaction. For example, if you try to get someone not to vaccinate their kids, fear may work. If there's, you know, an apple that looks bad, I don't eat it. Fear is actually not such a good motivator for inducing action, while hope is a better motivator on average for motivating action.
公共卫生官员利用恐惧来让我们戒烟。我问塔莉，恐惧是否可能是说服人们改变想法、甚至可能是改变行为的有效方法。恐惧在两种情况下管用。当人们已经处于压力之中、准备好采取行动时，它管用；而当你试图让某人“不做”某事——即不采取行动时，它也管用。例如，如果你试图让某人不给孩子接种疫苗，恐惧可能会起作用。如果有，你知道的，一个看起来很坏的苹果，我就不吃它。事实上，恐惧并不是促使人们采取行动的好动力，而希望通常才是激发行动更好的动力。
You talk about one study in your book where a hospital managed to get its workers to practice hand hygiene to get staff members to wash their hands regularly. But it turned out the most effective thing was in frightening the staff about the risks of transmitting infections. It was something else. So in a hospital on the East Coast, a camera was installed to see how often medical staff actually sanitize their hand before and after entering a patient's room. And the medical staff knew that the camera was installed, and yet only one in 10 medical staff
你在书中提到过一项研究，一家医院设法让其员工实践手部卫生，让员工定期洗手。但事实证明，最有效的方法并不是通过吓唬员工来让他们意识到传播感染的风险。而是别的东西。因此，在东海岸的一家医院，安装了一个摄像头，用来观察医务人员在进入和离开患者病房前后实际给双手消毒的频率。医务人员知道摄像头安装好了，然而每10名医务人员中只有1人
sanitize their hands before and after entering a patient's room. But then an intervention was introduced, an electronic board that was put above each door. And it gave the medical staff in real time positive feedback. It showed them the percentage of medical staff that washed their hands in the current shift and the weekly rate as well. So anytime a medical staff will wash their hands, the numbers will immediately go up and there will be a positive feedback saying, you know, good job.
在进出患者病房前后给双手消毒。但随后引入了一项干预措施，在每扇门上方安装了一个电子显示屏。它实时向医务人员提供积极的反馈。它向他们展示了当前班次中洗手的医务人员的百分比以及每周的比率。因此，每当有医务人员洗手时，数字就会立即上升，并且会出现一条积极的反馈，上面写着，你知道的，干得好。
And that affected the likelihood of people washing their hands significantly. It went up from 10% to 90% and it stayed there. Instead of using the normal approach, instead of saying, you know, you have to wash their head your hands because otherwise you'll spread the disease, basically instead of warning them of all the bad things that can happen in the future, which actually results in inaction, they gave them positive feedback. I wrapped up my conversation with Tali by exploring another idea about how we might convince others to listen to views that conflict with their own. It had to do with a study of Princeton students who got their brains scanned while they listened to stirring emotional speeches.
这显著影响了人们洗手的可能性。它从10%上升到了90%，并且一直保持在这个水平。他们没有使用常规的方法，没有说，你知道的，你必须洗手，否则你会传播疾病——基本上没有警告他们未来可能发生的所有坏事（这实际上会导致无所作为），而是给了他们积极的反馈。我与塔莉的对话结束于探讨另一个想法：我们如何才能说服他人去倾听与他们自身观点相冲突的观点。这与一项关于普林斯顿大学学生的研究有关，他们在聆听激昂的情感演讲时接受了大脑扫描。
What they found was the brains of the different people listening to those speeches started synchronizing. So if we all listen, for example, to Kennedy's famous moon speech, her brains would likely look very much alike. Those who came before us made certain that this country rolled the first waves of the industrial revolution. And this is not only in regions that are important for language and hearing, it's also in regions that are important for emotion, in regions that are important for what's known as fear of mind, our ability to think about what other people are thinking, in regions that are important for what's known as fear of mind, our ability to think about what other people are thinking and regions are important for associations.
研究发现，听这些演讲的不同人群的大脑开始同步。因此，如果我们都去听，例如肯尼迪著名的登月演讲，我们的大脑看起来可能会非常相似。我们的前人确保了这个国家引领了工业革命的第一波浪潮。这不仅发生在对语言和听觉重要的区域，也发生在对情感重要的区域，在对被称为心理理论（即思考他人想法的能力）重要的区域，在对被称为心理理论（即思考他人想法的能力）重要的区域，以及对联想重要的区域。
And you try to think, well, what's common to all these influential speeches that can cause so many people's activity to synchronize? And one of the most important things is emotion. If the storyteller or the person giving the speech is able to elicit emotion in the other person, then he's actually having somewhat of a control on that person's state of mind. And this generation does not intend to founder in the backwash of the coming age of space. We mean to be a part of it, we mean to lead it. So think about it like this. If you're very sad and I'm telling you a joke, well, you're sad. So you're not going to perceive the joke as I perceive it when I'm happy.
然后你试着思考，所有这些能够引发如此多人的活动同步的有影响力的演讲，它们的共同点是什么？其中最重要的一点就是情感。如果讲故事的人或发表演讲的人能够唤起另一个人的情感，那么他实际上就在某种程度上控制了那个人的精神状态。而这一代人不打算在即将到来的太空时代的泡沫中沉没。我们要成为它的一部分，我们要领导它。所以可以这样想。如果你非常伤心，而我给你讲了个笑话，好吧，你是伤心的。所以你不会像我快乐时那样去理解这个笑话。
But if I'm able to first make you happy and then tell you the joke, well, then you perceive it more from my point of view. So by eliciting emotion, what you're able to do is change the perception of everything that comes after, to perceive information as the person who's giving the speech wants you to perceive it. So you can see how this coupling, this idea that the audience is mind and the speaker's mind are in some ways coupled together. You can see how this could potentially be used to spread good information, you that the audience is mind and the speaker's mind are in some ways coupled together. You can see how this could potentially be used to spread good information.
但如果我能先让你快乐，然后再给你讲这个笑话，好吧，那你就会更多地从我的角度去理解它。因此，通过唤醒情感，你所能做的是改变对随后一切事物的感知，让人们按照演讲者希望你感知的方式去感知信息。所以你可以看到这种耦合——受众的大脑与演讲者的大脑在某些方面耦合在一起的这种想法。你可以看到这如何潜在地被用来传播良好的信息，受众的大脑与演讲者的大脑在某些方面耦合在一起的这种想法。你可以看到这如何潜在地被用来传播良好的信息。
You have a great teacher in high school and you're captivated by the teacher and you're being pulled along by the story the teacher is telling you, maybe about history or maybe about geography. But you can also see equally how the same thing can work in the opposite direction. That you could be listening to a demagogue or you could be listening to somebody who has who has a very sort of captivating rhetorical style, and this person could also lead you astray in just the same way that the great teacher can lead you to knowledge and positive things.
你在高中时有一位伟大的老师，你被这位老师深深吸引，被他讲述的故事——也许是关于历史的，也许是关于地理的——一路牵引着向前。但你同样也能看到，事情完全可以朝相反的方向发展。你可能会去听一个煽动者的演讲，或者你可能会去听一个有着某种非常迷人的修辞风格的人的演讲，而这个人也同样会把你引入歧途，就像伟大的老师引导你走向知识和积极的事物一样。
Absolutely. All the different factors that affect whether we will be influenced by one person or ignore another person are the same whether the person has good intentions or bad intentions, right? The factors that affect whether your influential can be, can you enlist an emotion in the other person? Can you tell a story? Are you taking into account the state of mind of the person that's in front of you? Are you giving them data that confirms to their
绝对是的。所有那些影响我们是被一个人所影响还是忽视另一个人的各种因素，无论这个人是怀有善意还是恶意，都是一样的，对吧？那些影响你是否具有影响力的因素可以是：你能否调动另一个人的情感？你能否讲好一个故事？你是否考虑了你面前这个人的精神状态？你是否在提供符合他们
preconceived notions? All those factors that make one speech more influential than the other or more likely to create an impact can be used for good and can be used for bad. Tali Sharter, I want to thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. We've been exploring why we cling to beliefs. After the break, we look at how we spread them, from person to person to person. We'll talk to a mathematician about the power of social networks to circulate ideas. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and you're listening to Hidden Brain.
先入为主观念的数据？所有那些让一场演讲比另一场更具影响力、或更有可能产生影响的因素，既可以用于行善，也可以用于作恶。塔莉·沙雷特，我要感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。我们一直在探讨我们为什么紧抓信念不放。稍事休息后，我们将探讨我们是如何传播它们的，从一个人到另一个人，再到另一个人。我们将与一位数学家探讨社交网络传播理念的力量。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. During the Middle Ages, words spread to Europe about a peculiar plant found in Asia. This plant had a long stalk with heavy pods attached. When you cut those pods open, inside you would find a tiny little lamb. Complete with flesh and wool like a live animal lamb. This creature, half plant, half animal, came to be known as the vegetable lamb of tartarie. Various travel writers wrote that they had either heard about this or that they had eaten one of these lambs and many of them said they had saw the kind of downy wool from the
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在中世纪，欧洲流传着关于亚洲一种奇特植物的传言。这种植物有着长长的茎，上面挂着沉重的豆荚。当你切开这些豆荚时，会发现里面有一只极小的羊。它完完整整地长着像活体小羊一样的肉和羊毛。这种半植物半动物的生物后来被称为“鞑靼之植物羊”。各种旅行作家写道，他们要么听说过这种羊，要么吃过其中一只，许多人还说他们亲眼见过那种羊身上
lamb. When these narratives made their way to Europe, people felt they had a view of a different world. Of course, no one in Europe had ever seen the vegetable lamb of Tarteri because there was no such thing. But for centuries, people kept talking about this fantastical creature as if it were real. It even came up in scholarly works right next to pictures of oak trees and rabbits. If people hadn't been telling each other about these things, nobody would believe that
毛茸茸的羊毛。当这些故事传到欧洲时，人们觉得他们得以窥见一个不同的世界。当然，欧洲从来没有人见过鞑靼之植物羊，因为根本没有这种东西。但几个世纪以来，人们一直在谈论这个奇幻的生物，就好像它是真实存在的一样。它甚至出现在学术著作中，紧挨着橡树和兔子的图片。如果人们没有互相谈论这些事情，没有人会相信
there were vegetable lambs because nobody had ever seen them, right? And this is by no means a unique happening at that time. At that time, of course, we would never fall for vegetable lambs. We live in an era of science, of evidence-based reasoning, of calm, cool analysis. But maybe there are vegetable lambs that persist even today, even among highly trained, scientist, physicians, and researchers. Maybe there are spectacularly bad ideas that we haven't yet recognized as spectacularly bad. Kaden Okonaer is a philosopher and mathematician at the University of California Irvine. She studies how information, both good and bad, can pass from person to person. She is co-author
有植物羊这种东西，因为从来没有人见过它们，对吧？这在当时绝不是一个孤立的事件。当然，在那个时代，我们绝不会轻信植物羊。我们生活在一个科学的时代、基于证据推理的时代、冷静客观分析的时代。但也许直到今天，即使在受过高度训练的科学家、医生和研究人员中，仍然存在着一些“植物羊”。也许有些极其糟糕的想法，我们至今还没有认清它们有多么糟糕。凯琳·奥康纳是加州大学欧文分校的哲学家和数学家。她研究好的和坏的信息是如何在人与人之间传递的。她与詹姆斯·韦瑟罗尔合著了
with James Weatherall of the book, The Misinformation Age, How Faults Beliefs Spread. Kaelin, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you for having me. So one of the fundamental premises in your book is that human beings are extremely dependent on the opinions and knowledge of other people. And this is what creates channels for fake news to flourish and spread. Let's talk about this idea. Can you give me some sense of our dependence on what you call the testimony of others? So our dependence on what you call the testimony of others. So one reason we wrote this book is that we noticed that a lot of people thinking about fake news and false belief were thinking about problems with individual psychology. So the way we have biases and processing information, the fact that we're bad at probability.
《错误信息时代：虚假信念如何传播》一书。凯琳，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，谢谢你们邀请我。那么，你书中的基本前提之一是，人类极其依赖其他人的意见和知识。而这正是假新闻滋生和传播的渠道。我们来谈谈这个想法。你能谈谈我们对你所谓的“他人证言”的依赖程度吗？所以我们对你所谓的“他人证言”的依赖。我们写这本书的原因之一是，我们注意到很多人在思考假新闻和虚假信念时，关注的都是个体心理学的问题。比如我们处理信息时存在的偏误，以及我们在概率计算上的拙劣表现。
But if you think about the things you believe, almost every single belief you have has come from another person. And that's just where we get our beliefs because we're social animals. And that's really wonderful for us. That's why we have culture and technology. You know, that's how we went to the moon. But if you imagine this social spread of beliefs as opening a door when you open a door for true beliefs to spread from person to person, you also open the door for false beliefs
但如果你想想你所相信的事物，你几乎持有的每一个信念都是从另一个人那里得来的。这就是我们获取信念的方式，因为我们是社会性动物。这对我们来说真的非常棒。这就是我们拥有文化和科技的原因。你知道，这就是我们如何登上月球的。但如果你把信念的这种社会化传播想象成打开一门大门——当你为真理在人与人之间的传播打开一门大门时，你也同时打开了虚假信念
to spread from person to person. So it's this kind of double-sided coin. And what's interesting, of course, is that if you close the door, you close the door to both, and if you open the door, you open the door to both, and if you open the door, you open the door to both. That's right. So if you want to be social learners who can do the kinds of cultural things we can do, it has to be the case that you also have to have this channel by which you can spread
在人与人之间传播的大门。所以这就像是一枚硬币的两面。当然，有趣的是，如果你关上这扇门，你就把两者的门都关上了；如果你打开这扇门，你就把两者的门都打开了，如果你打开这扇门，你就把两者的门都打开了。没错。因此，如果你想成为能够完成我们所能创造的那类文化成就的社会化学习者，那就必然意味着你也必须拥有这样一个渠道，通过它你同样会传播
falsehood and misinformation, too. So as I was reading the book, I was reflecting on the things that I know, or the things that I think I know, and I couldn't come up with a good answer for how I actually know that it's the earth that revolts around the sun and not the other way around. Yeah, that's right. 99% of the things you believe probably you have no direct evidence of yourself. You have to trust other people to find those things out, get the evidence, and tell it to you. And so one thing that we talk a lot about in the book is the fact that we all have to ground our beliefs in social trust. So we have to decide what sources and what people we trust, and therefore what beliefs
虚假信息和错误信息。所以在读这本书时，我一直在反思我所知道的事情，或者我以为我知道的事情，而对于我究竟如何知道是地球绕着太阳转、而不是反过来，我却给不出一个好的答案。是的，没。你所相信的事情中，有99%你可能自己都没有直接的证据。你必须信任其他人去发现这些事情、获取证据并告诉你。因此，我们在书中经常讨论的一个事实是，我们所有人都必须将我们的信念建立在社会信任的基础之上。所以我们必须决定我们信任哪些来源、信任哪些人，从而决定我们将采纳哪些信念
we're going to take up. Because there's just this problem where we cannot go, verify everything that we learn directly, we have to trust someone else to do that for us. We trust the historian who teaches us about Christopher Columbus. We trust the images from NASA showing how our solar system is organized. Now, we say we know Columbus was Italian, and we know the Earth revolves around the sun, but really what we mean to say is we trust the teacher and we trust NASA to tell us what is true.
。因为这里存在这样一个问题：我们无法亲自去验证我们所学的一切，我们必须信任别人来为我们做这件事。我们信任教导我们克里斯托弗·哥伦布的历史学家。我们信任美国宇航局（NASA）展示我们太阳系如何排列的图像。现在，我们说我们知道哥伦布是意大利人，我们也知道地球绕着太阳转，但实际上我们的意思是，我们信任老师，我们信任美国宇航局来告诉我们什么是真实的。
And the social trust and ability to spread beliefs, I mean it's remarkable what it's let humans do, you know, no other animal has this ability to sort of transfer ideas and knowledge dependably from person to person over generation after generation to accumulate that knowledge. But you do just see sometimes very funny examples of false beliefs being spread in the same way. As a philosopher of science,
这种社会信任和传播信念的能力——我是说，它让人类做出了不起的事情，你知道，没有其他动物有这种能力，能够在一代又一代人之间，可靠地将理念和知识从一个人传递给另一个人，从而积累这些知识。但你有时确实会看到非常有趣的虚假信念以同样的方式传播的例子。作为一名科学哲学家，
Kalen studies how scientists communicate and share information. If we rely on scientists to tell us what to believe, who do they rely on? Turns out, other scientists. Now showing that this is the case isn't easy. The process by which scientists change their minds on questions such as the spread of disease or the movement of objects through space is very complex.
凯琳研究科学家如何交流和分享信息。如果我们依赖科学家来告诉我们该相信什么，那么他们又依赖谁呢？事实证明，他们依赖其他科学家。现在要证明这一点并不容易。科学家在诸如疾病传播或物体在空间中的运动等问题上改变看法的过程是非常复杂的。
Studying this complex process can be mind-boggling. Say, for instance, Dr. A, Dr. Dr. B one day about her research. Hello. It also turns out that Dr. B is collaborating with Dr. C, who recently met Dr. D at a conference. Now, Dr. D frequently reads Dr. A's papers, but doesn't know about Dr. C's research. A couple of years later, Dr. E reads what Dr. B is written about what Dr. A said in an article that Dr. C cited before Dr. F had even published her results.
研究这个复杂的过程可能会让人眼花缭乱。比方说，A博士某天向B博士讲述了她的研究。你好。事实证明，B博士还在与C博士合作，而C博士最近在一次会议上遇到了D博士。现在，D博士经常阅读A博士的论文，但并不知道C博士的研究。几年后，E博士阅读了B博士写的内容——关于A博士在一篇文章中所说的话，而这篇文章在F博士甚至还没有发表她的结果之前就被C博士引用了。
Imperically it's hard to study scientists because things like theory change will happen over the course of 10 or 20 years and involve thousands and thousands of interactions between different scientists. You know, how would you ever study that? How would you ever study that? How would you ever study that? Because Kaelin can't follow all these interactions, she recreates them in a computer simulation. You'd want to think of it as a really kind of simplified representation of what's happening in the real world. She creates groups of fictional scientists and she gives them a series of rules like who they can talk to and who they trust.
从经验主义来看，研究科学家很困难，因为像理论变革这样的事情会在10年或20年的时间里发生，并涉及不同科学家之间成千上万次的互动。你知道，你怎么可能研究那个呢？你怎么可能研究那个呢？你怎么可能研究那个呢？因为凯琳无法追踪所有这些互动，她在计算机模拟中重现了它们。你可以把它想象成对现实世界中发生的事情的一种非常简化的表征。她创建了虚构的科学家群体，并给他们一系列规则，比如他们可以和谁说话、他们信任谁。
These simulated scientists collect data and discuss their simulated research. Kaelin sits back and watches what happens. So one thing we find sometimes in these models is that one agent or scientist will get data supporting the false belief. They'll share it with the entire community of scientists, and then everyone will come to all believe the false thing at once and sort of ignore a better theory. And part of what happens there is this social spread of knowledge and belief, causing everyone to turn away from a good theory. So if you have almost too much social influence
这些模拟的科学家收集数据并讨论他们的模拟研究。凯琳坐在一旁观察会发生什么。所以我们在这些模型中有时会发现的一件事是，某个智能体或科学家会得到支持虚假信念的数据。他们会将其分享给整个科学家群体，然后每个人都会一下子开始相信这个虚假的东西，并某种程度上忽视一个更好的理论。其中一部分原因就在于知识和信念的这种社会化传播，导致每个人都背离了一个好的理论。因此，如果你在社群内部拥有
within a community, that can be really bad because everyone can stop gathering data since the entire community is exposed to the same spurious results. If I hear you correctly, what you're saying is that psychological factors can have an effect, but you can have the spread of bad information even in the absence of biases or stupidity.
几乎过多的社会影响力，那可能会非常糟糕，因为每个人都可能停止收集数据，既然整个社区都暴露在相同的虚假结果之中。如果我没理解错的话，你的意思是心理因素会产生影响，但即使在没有偏误或愚蠢的情况下，你也会遭遇糟糕信息的传播。
Yeah, so one way that the models we look at are really useful is that you can kind of pair away things that are happening in the real world and see, well, suppose we didn't have any psychological biases, suppose we were perfectly rational, would we always come to the right answer in science and in our day-to-day lives and see that the answer is no? scientific communities that show how good information sometimes fails to spread and how bad information can metastasize. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. Mathematician and philosopher Kaila Nokhana studies how information spreads through social networks. People who know and trust one another efficiently pass information back and forth and learn from one another. Unfortunately, the same rules of social trust can sometimes be a roadblock for the truth. Mary Wartley Montague learned this lesson hundreds of years ago. She was an English aristocrat who found herself living for a while
是的，所以我们研究的模型非常有用的一种方式是，你可以剥离现实世界中正在发生的事情，然后思考：假设我们没有任何心理偏误，假设我们是完全理性的，我们在科学和日常生活中就一定能得出正确的答案吗？你会发现答案是否定的。展示了好的信息有时如何无法传播，而坏的信息又如何能像 metastasize（恶性扩散）一样蔓延。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。数学家兼哲学家凯琳·奥康纳研究信息如何在社交网络中传播。彼此相识且信任的人高效地来回传递信息并相互学习。不幸的是，社会信任的规则有时也会成为真理的绊脚石。玛丽·沃特利·蒙塔古在几百年前就吸取了这一教训。她是一位英国贵族，曾有一段时间生活在
in what is modern day Turkey. So Mary Montague seems to have been really enchanted by Turkish culture. You know, she was coming from England and aristocratic culture there. In Turkey, she discovered these beautiful shopping centers, she was coming from England and aristocratic culture there. In Turkey, she discovered these beautiful shopping centers, bath houses, she seems to have been enchanted by bath houses where there would be a lot of women sort of lounging naked, going in the hot water, drinking hot drinks together.
如今的土耳其境内。玛丽·蒙塔古似乎对土耳其文化着迷不已。你知道，她来自英国以及那里的贵族文化。在土耳其，她发现了这些美丽的购物中心，她来自英国以及那里的贵族文化。在土耳其，她发现了这些美丽的购物中心、澡堂，她似乎对澡堂着迷，那里会有许多女性赤身裸体地闲逛、泡热水澡、一起喝热饮。
Another thing that struck Mary about Turkish women, they used an innovative technique to limit the spread of smallpox. It was called variolation. What this involved, I mean, it's a bit like vaccination now. You would scratch maybe the arm of a patient and take a pus from a smallpox post-tool and put that pus into the scratch. So what would happen after you did that is that the patient would get a very mild small pox infection.
玛丽对土耳其女性的另一个印象是，她们使用了一种创新的技术来限制天花的传播。这被称为人痘接种法。这涉及的内容，我的意思是，它有点像现在的疫苗接种。你可能会划破病人的手臂，取一处天花脓疱里的脓液，然后把脓液放进划痕里。这样做之后发生的情况是，患者会感染非常轻微的天花。
Some small percentage of patients would die, but many, many fewer than who would die of an actual smallpox infection. And after they had that more mild infection, they would actually be immune to smallpox. So this was practiced commonly in Turkey, basically unheard of in England at the time. Mary Montague had herself had smallpox and survived when she was younger. She had lost a brother to smallpox. And so when she encountered variolation in Turkey, she decided, well, you know, why don't we do this in England? She had her own son variolated, and she decided she was going to try to spread this practice in her native country.
极少数比例的患者会死亡，但这比死于真正的天花感染的人要少得多、少得多。在经历这种较轻的感染后，他们实际上就会对天花免疫。所以这在土耳其很常见，但在当时的英国简直闻所未闻。玛丽·蒙塔古年轻时自己曾感染过天花并幸存下来。她曾因天花失去了一个弟弟。因此，当她在土耳其遇到人痘接种时，她决定，嗯，你知道的，为什么我们不在英国也这样做呢？她给自己儿子接种了人痘，并决定试图在自己的祖国推广这种做法。
So when she returns to Britain, in some ways, Mary Montague here functions like one of your agents in your computer models, because you have one cluster over here in Turkey, and one cluster over here in Britain. And essentially, you have an agent walking over from Turkey to Britain. And Mary Montague says, here's this wonderful idea. We can limit the spread of smallpox in Britain. Britain, in fact, at the time time was actually facing a smallpox crisis. How are her ideas received? So, her ideas were not received very well when she first came back. One thing we talk a lot about in the book is that almost everyone has what you might call
因此，当她返回英国时，在某些情况下，这里的玛丽·蒙塔古就像你计算机模型中的某个智能体，因为你在这里土耳其有一个集群，而在英国这里有另一个集群。本质上，你有一个智能体从土耳其走到英国。玛丽·蒙塔古说，这是一个绝妙的主意。我们可以限制天花在英国的传播。事实上，当时的英国正面临天花的危机。她的观点受到了怎样的对待？所以，她刚回来时，她的观点并没有受到很好的接待。我们在书中经常讨论的一件事是，几乎每个人都有你可能会称之为
a conformist bias. We don't like to publicly state things that are different from the people in our social networks, we don't like to have beliefs that are different from the people around us, it's somehow very socially uncomfortable to do that, and we don't like our actions to not conform with the people who we know and love. So when she got back to England, you know, it was already the case that all these physicians in England didn't believe in variolation. They thought this was a crazy idea. And none of them were going to stand out from the pack of physicians and say, yeah,
从众偏误的东西。我们不喜欢公开说出与我们社交网络中的人不同的话，我们不喜欢拥有与周围人不同的信念，这样做在某种程度上让人在社交上感到非常不舒服，而且我们也不喜欢自己的行为与我们认识和喜爱的人不一致。所以当她回到英国时，你知道的，英国所有的这些医生本来就不相信人痘接种。他们认为这是一个疯狂的主意。而且他们中没有人愿意从这群医生中脱颖而出说，是的
I'm the person who's going to try this or going to believe that this practice works because they were all busy conforming with each other. And of course, these ideas were coming from another country, a country with very different cultural practices that seemed in some ways very foreign, the idea and the country itself seemed very foreign. That's right. So it's not just that it's a weird new idea that none of them believe in their kind of in-group.
我是那种会去尝试或者相信这种做法有效的人，因为大家都在忙着互相顺从。当然，这些想法来自另一个 country，一个文化习俗大不相同的 country，在某些方面显得非常陌生，这个想法以及这个 country 本身都显得非常陌生。没错。所以不仅仅是因为这是一个他们所在的内群体中没有人相信的奇怪新想法。
It's also that it's a weird new idea that none of them believe in their kind of in-group. It's also that it's coming from Turkey and furthermore, it's coming from women in Turkey, so it was a practice mostly done by women, and a woman is bringing it to England as well. So they also don't really trust her as a woman and someone who's not a physician. trust her as a woman and someone who's not a physician. So social trust is a really important aspect in understanding how people form beliefs because we can't go out and figure out ourselves whether the things people tell us are true. Usually we just always have to decide who to trust and people have little shortcuts in how they do this. They tend to trust those who are more like them.
还因为它是一个他们所在的内群体中没有人相信的奇怪新想法。还因为它来自土耳其，而且，它来自土耳其的女性，所以这主要是女性做的做法，而且一个女性也把它带到了英国。所以他们作为女性和非医师，其实也并不真正信任她。作为女性和非医师，信任她。因此，在理解人们如何形成信念时，社会信任是一个非常重要的方面，因为我们无法亲自出去弄清楚别人告诉我们的事情是否属该。通常我们总是不得不决定信任谁，人们在这方面的做法有一些小捷径。他们往往会信任那些更像他们的人。
They also tend to trust those who share beliefs and values and practices with them. So for example, if you are a physician, you might tend to trust a physician. If you believe in homeopathy, you might tend to trust someone who believes in homeopathy. We all use these kinds of tricks. So what we saw in the variation case with Mary Montague, the physicians aren't going to trust this woman who doesn't share their beliefs and practices, who isn't much like them. Now you could argue that the physicians who rejected Mary Montague's ideas were not behaving like real scientists. They weren't being dispassionate, they weren't being objective.
他们也往往会信任那些与他们有共同信念、价值观和做法的人。所以例如，如果你是一名医生，你可能会倾向于信任医生。如果你相信顺势疗法，你可能会倾向于信任相信顺势疗法的人。我们都使用这些技巧。所以我们在玛丽·蒙塔ague（Mary Montague）的变痘案例中看到的是，医生们不会信任这个不分享他们的信念和做法、与他们不太一样的女人。现在你可以争辩说，拒绝玛丽·蒙塔ague想法的医生们的行为不像真正的科学家。他们不是冷静的，他们不是客观的。
They were bringing psychological biases into the picture. Sexism, xenophobia, tribalism. In the real world, misinformation spreads because of some combination of network effects and psychological and cognitive biases. You see the same thing in the case of the Hungarian physician Ignas Semmelweis. He was an insider, a man, and a doctor. He even had the assistance of scientific evidence to support his claims. But it turned out even these were not enough to overcome the barriers that confront the truth. Ignor Simalayas was a physician living in Vienna.
他们把心理偏见带入了画面。性别歧视、仇外心理、部落主义。在现实世界中，错误信息的传播是网络效应以及心理和认知偏见的某种组合造成的。你在匈牙利医生伊格纳斯·塞梅尔魏斯（Ignas Semmelweis）的案例中看到了同样的事情。他是一个圈内人，一个男人，也是一名医生。他甚至有科学证据来支持他的主张。但事实证明，即使这些也不足以克服阻碍真理的障碍。伊格纳·西马拉亚斯（Ignor Simalayas）是一名住在维也纳的医生。
He was bitten charge of this clinic, the first obstetrical clinic in Vienna. Next door was the second obstetrical clinic in Vienna. Next door was the second obstetrical clinic of Vienna. He was in charge of training new doctors and obstetrics, and at the second clinic, they were training midwives. And shortly after he took over, he realized that something really terrible was going on because in his clinic, 10% of the women were dying, mostly of childbed fever. While the midwives
他负责这家诊所，维也纳的第一家产科诊所。隔壁是维也纳的第二家产科诊所。隔壁是维也纳的第二家产科诊所。他负责培训新医生和产科，而在第二家诊所，他们培训助产士。在他接手后不久，他意识到发生了一些非常可怕的事情，因为在他的诊所里，10% 的女性死亡，大多死于产褥热。而助产士
next door who presumably, you know, they would have thought they were less expertise, only three to four percent of their patients were dying. So Somalwise was obviously really worried about this. He had patients who would be begging on their knees to be transferred to the other clinic. He had this kind of breakthrough moment when a colleague of his was conducting an autopsy and accidentally cut himself. And then shortly thereafter, he died of something that looked a lot like child bed fever. Some of us realized, well, I've got all these physicians who are conducting autopsy's on cadavers and then immediately going and delivering babies.
隔壁的人可能认为他们没有那么专业的经验，但他们的病人只有百分之三到四的人死亡。所以索马尔维斯显然对此非常担心。他的病人在膝盖上乞求转到另一家诊所。当他的一个同事在做尸检时不小心割伤了自己时，他有了这种突破性的时刻。然后不久之后，他死于一种看起来很像产褥热的病。我们中的一些人意识到，嗯，我有所有这些医生在尸体上做尸检，然后立即去接生婴儿。
And he thought, well, maybe there's something transferred on their hands. And you call this cadaverous particles. Of course, now we know that that is bacteria, but they didn't have a theory of bacteria at the time. So he started requiring the physicians to wash their hands in a chlorinated solution and the death rate in his clinic dropped way down. And of course, the way we think about science, we say, all right, we've someone's discovered something wonderful. Everyone must have instantly adopted this brilliant new idea.
他想，也许他们的手上传递了什么东西。你称之为尸体颗粒。当然，现在我们知道那是细菌，但他们当时没有细菌理论。因此，他开始要求医生在氯化溶液中洗手，他诊所的死亡率大幅下降。当然，我们对科学的思考方式是，好吧，我们有人发现了极好的东西。每个人都一定立即采用了这个精彩的新想法。
You would think, right? And he has this wonderful evidence, right? It was 10%. He introduced the practice, goes down to 3%, but that's not what happened. So he published his ideas, and the other gentleman physicians did not take them up. In fact, they found them kind of offensive, they thought this is, you know, he's writing that we have dirty hands, we have unclean hands, but in fact we're gentleman.
你会这么想，对吧？他有这么棒的证据，对吧？那是 10%。他引入了这种做法，降到了 3%，但事情并非如此。所以他发表了他的想法，其他绅士医生并没有接受。事实上，他们觉得这有点冒犯，他们认为这是，你知道的，他写道我们的手很脏，我们的手不干净，但实际上我们是绅士。
They also thought it was just really far out of the range of theories that could possibly be true. So they didn't believe him despite the really good evidence and the deep importance, you know, people's lives were really at stake. And it took decades for his handwashing practice to actually spread. In fact, I understand that Semmelweis himself eventually suffered a nervous breakdown. How did his own story end? So the way the story goes, though this is a little hard to verify, is that he was so frustrated
他们还认为这远远超出了可能是真的理论范围。所以尽管有很好的证据和深远的重要性，你知道，人们的生命真的处于危险之中，他们还是不相信他。他的洗手做法花了数十年时间才真正传播开来。事实上，据我了解，塞梅尔魏斯本人最终精神崩溃了。他自己的故事是怎么结束的？所以故事是这样的，尽管这有点难以核实，他是如此沮丧
that people weren't adopting his handwashing practice that he had a nervous breakdown as a result. He was put into a V&E's mental hospital where he was beaten by guards and died of a blood poisoning a few weeks later. We've seen how being an outsider or breaking with tradition can be barriers to the spread of good scientific information. But you could argue that these examples were from a long gone era of gentlemen physicians and amateur scientists.
人们没有采用他的洗手做法，导致他精神崩溃。他被送进维也纳的一家精神病院，在那里遭到警卫殴打，几周后死于败血症。我们已经看到，局外人或打破传统如何成为传播良好科学信息的障碍。但你可以争辩说，这些例子来自一个早已逝去的绅士医生和业余科学家的时代。
But even in the modern day of science where researchers demand hard evidence to be convinced, it turns out that false, inaccurate, and incomplete information can still take hold. In 1954, ED Palmer published a paper that changed how doctors thought about stomach ulcers. So what he did was looked at a lot of stomachs. I believe somewhere in the range of a thousand. And he found that there were no bacteria whatsoever in the stomachs that he investigated. A lot of people at that time had been arguing over whether stomach ulcers were caused by stomach acid
但即使在现代科学中，研究人员要求确凿的证据才能被说服，事实证明虚假、不准确和不完整的信息仍然可以扎根。1954 年，爱德华·帕尔默（ED Palmer）发表了一篇论文，改变了医生对胃溃疡的看法。所以他做的是检查了很多胃。我相信在千左右的范围内。他发现他调查的胃里没有任何细菌。
or some kind of bacteria. This was taken as really decisive evidence showing that, okay, well, it can't be bacteria because everyone thought Palmer's study showed there are no bacteria in stomachs, so it absolutely must be stomach acid. And of course, in this case, Palmer was not trying to fabricate his data or make up data. He was sincerely arriving at what he thought was a very good conclusion. That's right. And it seems that it just was a problem with his methodology. Of course, there are bacteria in our stomachs. He just didn't see them because of the way he was doing his particular experiment. This was not a fabrication at all. One of the things that's
当时很多人一直在争论胃溃疡是由胃酸引起的还是某种细菌引起的。这被视为真正决定性的证据，表明，好吧，它不可能是细菌，因为每个人都认为帕尔默的研究表明胃里没有细菌，所以绝对必须是胃酸。当然，在这种情况下，帕尔默并不是在试图捏造数据或编造数据。他真诚地得出了他认为是很好的结论。没错。这似乎只是他的方法论问题。当然，我们的胃里有细菌。由于他做特定实验的方式，他只是没有看到它们。这根本不是捏造。其中一件事
interesting about this episode involving Palmer and the Stamacal SARS is that as individuals essentially came over to believe what Palmer was telling them, there was a consensus that started to grow. And as each new person added to the consensus, it became a little bit stronger, which made it even harder to challenge. Yeah, so although they had been arguing for decades about whether ulcers were caused by acid or by bacteria, at this point people started to share palm-ish results pretty much everybody saw them, and this consensus was arrived at okay, it's acid, and everyone who
关于涉及帕尔默和胃溃疡的这一插曲有趣的是，当个人基本上开始相信帕尔默告诉他们的话时，开始形成一种共识。随着每个新人都加入到共识中，它变得稍微强大了一点，这使得挑战变得更加困难。是的，尽管他们争论了几十年溃疡是由酸还是细菌引起的，但此时人们开始分享帕尔默的结果，几乎每个人都看到了，并达成了这种共识，好吧，是酸，而每个人谁
had been studying the possibility that bacteria caused stomach ulcers stopped studying that. Well, not everyone. Fast forward a few decades to the early 1980s. In Australia, a physician named Barry Marshall grew skeptical of the acid theory. His experiment suggested that ulcers were caused by bacteria, not stomach acid. But this theory was met with stony face resistance. He couldn't
一直在研究细菌导致胃溃疡可能性的研究人员停止了研究。嗯，并非所有人。快进几十年到 20 世纪 80 年代初。在澳大利亚，一位名叫巴里·马歇尔（Barry Marshall）的医生对酸理论产生了怀疑。他的实验表明溃疡是由细菌引起的，而不是胃酸。但这一理论遇到了冷漠的抵抗。他甚至无法
even get his articles published. Scientists sniped at him behind his back, even though as it turns out, his data was far better than the stomach studies by Edie Palmer. Barry Marshall was frustrated that no one seemed willing to listen to his findings. So he figured out a way to get everyone's attention. The only person in the world at that time who could make an informed consent was me. So I had to be in my own experiment. And so he did this demonstration. He took bacteria from the stomach of one of his sick patients.
让他的文章发表。科学家们在背后对冷嘲热讽，尽管事实证明，他的数据比爱德华·帕尔默的胃研究好得多。巴里·马歇尔对似乎没有人愿意听取他的发现感到沮丧。所以他想出了一种吸引所有人注意的方法。当时世界上唯一能做出知情同意的人是我。所以我必须参与我自己的实验。于是他做了这个示范。他从一个生病病人的胃里提取了细菌。
So we cultured a patient with gastritis. He stood it into a broth, and then... I drank the bacteria, tented the ninth colony forming units. He gave himself stomach ulcers, and then he later cured them with antibiotics. In this publicity stunt, almost to convince people that in fact ulcers were and then he later cured them with antibiotics in this publicity stunt almost to convince people that in fact ulcers were caused by bacteria.
所以我们培养了一个胃炎患者。他把它放进肉汤里，然后……我喝了细菌，达到第九个菌落形成单位。他让自己得了胃溃疡，后来用抗生素治愈了它们。在这场宣传噱头上，几乎是为了说服人们实际上溃疡是然后他后来用抗生素治愈了他们，在这场宣传噱头上，几乎是为了说服人们实际上溃疡是由细菌引起的。
Eventually Barry Marshall and Robin Warren went on to win the Nobel Prize in Medicine for their discoveries. Mary Montague, the woman who faced resistance in bringing variation to England, never won a prestigious prize, but she also found a way to spread the truth. Like Barry Marshall, she found it had more to do with her sales pitch than with the evidence. So in the end, she did something really smart, which took advantage of the ways that we use our social connections to ground our beliefs and our trust. So she ended up convincing Princess Carolyn of Onesbach to variulate her own two small daughters
最终，巴里·马歇尔和罗宾·沃伦（Robin Warren）凭借他们的发现赢得了诺贝尔医学奖。玛丽·蒙塔ague，那个在将变痘引入英国时面临阻力的女人，从未赢得过声望很高的奖项，但她也找到了传播真理的方法。就像巴里·马歇尔一样，她发现这与她的销售说辞关系更大，而与证据关系不大。所以最后，她做了一件非常聪明的事情，利用了我们利用社会联系来建立我们的信念和信任的方式。所以她最终说服了昂斯巴赫的卡洛琳公主为她自己的两个小女儿进行变痘
and to do it in this kind of public way. So she got one of the most influential people in the entire country to engage in this practice. So that did two things. So number one, it made clear, you know, because she did in this kind of public way and her daughters were fine, it gave people evidence that this is in fact a safe practice and it's a good idea. But it also made clear to people that if they want to conform to the norm, if they want to share a practice with this really influential person, then they should do the same thing.
并以这种公开的方式去做。所以她让整个国家最有影响力的人之一参与到这项实践中。这做了两件事。所以第一，它让事情变得清楚，你知道，因为她以这种公开的方式做，她的女儿们都很好，它给人们提供了证据，证明这确实是一种安全的做法，是一个好主意。但也向人们明确表示，如果他们想顺应规范，如果他们想与这个非常有影响力的人分享一种做法，那么他们应该做同样的事情。
And after Princess Carolyn did this, Variolation spread much more quickly, especially among people who had a personal connection to either Mary Montague or to the princess. What's fascinating here is that this wasn't in some way a rational way to solve the problem. It wasn't saying, look, there's really convincing evidence here. You're almost using a technique that's pretty close to propaganda. It is a propaganda technique, absolutely. So, propaganda's tend to be very savvy
在卡洛琳公主这样做之后，变痘传播得快得多，特别是在与玛丽·蒙塔ague或公主有个人联系的人当中。这里迷人的是，这在某种程度上并不是解决问题的理性方式。它并不是说，看，这里有真正令人信服的证据。你几乎是在使用一种非常接近宣传的技术。这绝对是一种宣传技术。所以，宣传往往非常精明
about the ways that people use their social connections to ground trust and knowledge and choose their beliefs, and they take advantage of those. In this case, it was using that social trust for good, but in many cases, people use it for bad. And if you look at the history of industrial propaganda in the US, or if you look at the way Russia conducted propaganda before the last election,
关于人们利用社会联系建立信任和知识并选择信念的方式，他们利用了这一点。在这种情况下，它是为了善意而使用这种社会信任，但在许多情况下，人们将其用于恶意。如果你看看美国工业宣传的历史，或者如果你看看俄罗斯在上一次选举前进行宣传的方式，
people have taken advantage of these kinds of social ties and beliefs to try to convince us of whatever it is they're selling. One last idea and how you counter bad information, semilvice as we saw did not succeed in persuading other doctors during his lifetime to wash their hands thoroughly before they were treating patients. But of course, now that idea is widely adopted,
人们利用这些类型的社会联系和信念来试图说服我们他们正在出售的任何东西。最后一个想法以及如何反击不良信息，正如我们所看到的，塞梅尔维斯在他的一生中并没有成功说服其他医生在治疗病人之前彻底洗手。但当然，现在这个想法已被广泛采用，
what does that tell us, Kalin, about how signs in some ways might be self-correcting? It might not be self-correcting at the pace that we want, but over time, it appears that good ideas do beat out the bad ones. Yeah, so we have thousands and thousands of examples in science of exactly that happening of good ideas beating out the bad ones. Of course, now we can look back and say, oh, well, that could idea one out,
凯琳，这告诉我们科学在某些方面可能是自我纠正的？它可能没有以我们希望的速度进行自我纠正，但随着时间的推移，好主意似乎确实战胜了坏主意。是的，我们在科学中有成千上万个完全发生这种情况的例子，好主意战胜了坏主意。当然，现在我们可以回顾并说，哦，那个好主意赢了，
and that could idea one out. We can't actually look at right now and know which of the ideas we believe now are correct ones or good ones. So there are actually philosophers of science like Larry Loudon and Kyle Stanford who argue for something called the pessimistic meta-induction, which is something like this, because scientific theories in the past have always eventually been overturned,
那个好主意赢了。我们实际上不能现在看一眼就知道我们现在相信的哪个想法是正确的或好的。因此，实际上有科学哲学家如拉里·劳丹（Larry Laudan）和凯尔·斯坦福（Kyle Stanford）主张所谓的悲观元归纳，大约是这样的，因为过去的科学理论最终总是被推翻，
we ought to think that our theories now will probably be overturned as well. But there's actually an optimistic side to this, which is that if you look at many theories in the past, ones that were overturned, often the reason people believe them is that even if they were wrong, they were a good guide to action. Even the theory of stomach acid causing ulcers, well if you treat stomach acid, it actually does help with ulcers. It wasn't a completely unsuccessful theory. It's just that it wasn't totally right,
我们应该认为我们现在的理论也可能会被推翻。但实际上这有一个乐观的一面，那就是如果你看看过去的许多理论，那些被推翻的理论，人们相信它们的原因往往是，即使它们是错误的，它们也是行动的良好指南。即使是胃酸引起溃疡的理论，如果你治疗胃酸，它实际上对溃疡有帮助。这不是一个完全不成功的理论。只是它并不完全正确，
and it wasn't as successful as the bacteria theory of ulcers because antibiotics do better. One of the interesting implications about all of this is how we should think about the truth. And in some ways, I think the picture that I'm getting from you is a picture that says the truth is not a binary question. Is it true? Is it false? I mean, some questions, of course, perhaps can be reduced to, is it true? Is it false? But really, scientists in the business are producing probability estimates for various claims. And I think what
而且它不像溃疡的细菌理论那样成功，因为抗生素做得更好。这一切有趣的影响之一是我们应该如何思考真理。在某些方面，我认为我从你这里得到的图景是一幅说真理不是一个二元问题的图景。它是真的吗？它是假的吗？我的意思是，当然，有些问题也许可以简化为，它是真的吗？它是假的吗？但实际上，从事这项业务的科学家正在为各种主张产生概率估计。我想
you're saying is that for us to actually be on the right side of the misinformation, information divide, it's helpful for us to think in probabilistic terms rather than in binary terms. Yeah, that's absolutely right. So we do think it's really important to think about belief in terms of degrees and evidence and believing something strongly enough. And part of the reason is that there has been the strategy where people who are trying to subvert our beliefs will say, but we're not sure about something. They'll say, evolution's just a theory or there's some doubt about global
你所说的是，为了让我们真正站在错误信息、信息鸿沟的正确一边，用概率术语而不是二元术语思考对我们很有帮助。是的，这绝对是正确的。所以我们确实认为根据程度和证据以及对某事物的信念足够坚定来思考信念非常重要。部分原因在于存在这样一种策略，试图颠覆我们信念的人会说，但我们对某事并不确定。他们会说进化论只是一个理论，或者对全球存在一些怀疑
warming. But ultimately not being sure about something is not what matters. We're never really 100% sure about anything. And if you think about it, think about any belief you could have, you know, that the sun will come up tomorrow. Well, it always has in the past, but that doesn't mean that 100% sure it will tomorrow. There's a really good chance at will tomorrow. We shouldn't be looking for certainty. Instead, we need to be saying to ourselves, when do we have enough evidence to make good decisions?
变暖。但归根结底，对某事不确定并不是最重要的。我们对任何事情都从未真正100%确定。如果你想想看，想想你可能有的任何信念，你知道，太阳明天会升起。嗯，过去一直是这样，但这并不意味着100%确定明天会这样。明天有很大的几率会这样。我们不应该寻找确定性。相反，我们需要对自己说，我们什么时候才有足够的证据做出正确的决定？
Kaelin O'Connor is a philosopher and mathematician at the University of California, Irvine. She studies how social networks can spread both good information and bad. Along with James Weatherall, she is co-author of the book, The Misinformation Age, How Falls Beliefs Spread. Kaelin, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Bray. Oh, thank you so much for having me. This episode was produced by Maggie Penman, Camilla Vargas Restrepo and Laura Quarelle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah, Raina Cohen and Thomas Liu.
凯琳·奥康纳（Kaelin O'Connor）是加利福尼亚大学欧文分校的哲学家和数学家。她研究社交网络如何传播好信息和坏信息。她与詹姆斯·韦瑟尔（James Weatherall）共同合著了《错误信息时代：错误信念如何传播》（The Misinformation Age, How False Beliefs Spread）一书。凯琳，谢谢你今天加入我的《隐藏大脑》（Hidden Brain）。哦，非常感谢邀请我。本集由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、卡米拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Camilla Vargas Restrepo）和劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕思·沙阿（Parth Shah）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和刘托马斯（Thomas Liu）。
Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. For more Hidden Brain, please follow the show on Facebook and Twitter. I'm Shankar Vedantum. I'll see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的监督制片人是塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。欲了解更多《隐藏大脑》内容，请在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注该节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹图姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们下周见。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。